-Welcome back to "The Tonight Show."
We're going to play a mind-blowing game,
but first I'm going to need someone to play against.
He hit a record-breaking 62 home runs this season
and was named this year's
American League Most Valuable Player.
Please welcome the captain of the New York Yankees,
the one and only Aaron Judge!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're about to face off in a game called "Blow Your Mind."
[ Roots vocalizing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Questlove?!
Questlove, do you want to explain
how this game works, please?
[ Hissing ]
-Yes, Jimmy.
In this game, I will read each of you a mind-blowing fact.
And you must decide if that fact is true or false.
[Echoing] If you choose wrong,
we will blow your mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You will be blasted in the face
from the front of the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice, and your opponent gets their mind blown.
-Before we start, let's give ourselves
a little spritz of water.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. -Are we ready?
Aaron, you ready?
-Oh, yeah. -Alright.
The first fact is for Aaron.
-This is for Aaron. -Thank you, Jimmy.
Aaron, true or false?
Hunting unicorns is legal in Michigan.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Well, one of my best friends
went to the University of Michigan,
and he always talked about some hunting trips he went on.
He never told me what he was hunting.
[ Laughter ]
I got to go true. It's got to be true, right?
-Aaron, the answer may surprise you.
[ Music sting ]
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's true. Yeah. True.
Can we see that again in slow motion?
[ Laughter ]
-That -- -Another spray?
-That was cotton candy.
Yeah, please, another spray.
-Mmm! -Wow. I've never inhaled that.
That was fantastic.
Alright.
-Jimothy. -Yes.
-The next fact is for you.
Jimmy, true or false?
Chickens cluck with regional accents.
[ Laughter ]
-What did you -- What did you just say?
-Chickens cluck with regional accents.
-Regional accents. -Like a city chicken
will cluck different than a country chicken?
"Yo, hey, yo. Cluck, cluck over'ere.
Hey, hey, hey."
I think that is --
I would say that is false. -No way.
-Hm, Jimmy. The answer...
may surprise you. -Yeah, may surprise me.
-Yeah, yeah. -I've seen this show before.
-[ Music sting ] -[ Clears throat ]
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's false. -What was that?
-Let's see that again in slow motion.
[ Laughter ]
-Baby socks.
[ Laughs ] They were baby socks.
Fantastic.
Okay. Tie game.
-Aaron. -Spritz. Yeah. You look good.
-Aaron, you're up next.
So, true or false, Aaron...
Sid.
-The Cookie Monster.
-The Cookie Monster's real name...
-Is Sid.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, I don't think you knew this about me,
but I grew up on "Sesame Street," so...
-Do you ever --
-Of course. That's true.
-Wait. -I think it's true.
He looks like a Sid. He looks like a Sid.
-[as Cookie Monster] Me no have first name.
[ Laughter ]
Me Cookie Monster!
-He looks like a Sid. He's a Sid.
-The answer may surprise you.
-Yep. -Yeah.
[ Music sting ]
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was -- -It is true.
Can we see that again in slow motion?
-What was that that almost hit me?
Something went over my head. Oh, my gosh.
-The next fact is for you, Jimmy.
-Yeah, here we go. Sid? I never heard that.
-Sid, yeah. Sid Cookie.
-Oh, come on. That's not true. [ Laughs ]
-Jimmy, true or false. -Yeah.
-The blob of toothpaste that sits on your toothbrush
is called a "nurdle."
[ Laughter ]
A nurdle.
Nurdle.
-Nurdle. Nurdle.
-Stop saying "a nurdle" every time I --
Alright, the blob of toothpaste that sits on your toothbrush
is called a nurdle?
I don't think that has a name. I would say --
-Phone a friend. Phone a friend.
-Phone a friend? Audience?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Nurdle. Nurdle. It's a nurdle.
-It is a nurdle?
[ Audience shouting ]
I'm going to say -- I'm going to say --
[ Music sting ] I'm going to say --
[ Laughter ] Alright.
I'm going to say yes, or else everyone's
going to yell "nurdle" everywhere I go.
-So your answer is, yes, you think it's called a nurdle.
-Yeah.
[ Audience cheers ]
♪♪
-The answer may surprise you.
-Yeah.
[ Music sting ]
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is true.
Let's see that again in slow motion.
[ Audience chanting "Nurdle!" ]
-What is happening?
Alright. Okay.
[ Thunder crashes ]
What does this mean?
-Excuse me.
That sound means it's time for the final question.
And it comes with a twist. -What?
-If you answer incorrectly,
both of your minds will be blown.
-We're gonna help each other.
Aaron, this conundrum is for you.
Aaron, is water wet?
-What?!
-We're working together on this, right?
-Yeah, we're working together on this.
What do you -- This is a --
The answer... -Yeah.
-The answer m-- -True.
-Water -- -It's wet.
-But why would he ask us that?
"Is water wet?" -Is it?
-He wouldn't mess with us. He wouldn't mess with us.
-Is water wet?!
[ Audience shouting "No!" ]
-What do you mean no?
♪♪
Yes. -Yes.
It's wet. It's wet.
[ Audience shouting "No!" ]
-Answer the question, please. Is water wet?
-I'm just going to say -- -True.
-Yes.
-Well, the answer... may surprise you.
-May surprise you.
[ Music sting ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is incorrect.
Whatever is filled with water is wet,
but water itself is not wet.
-Aaron Judge, everybody! Water is not wet.
We're talking to Aaron after the break.
Stick around, everybody!